sorry a professor at Cornell and is
going to be talking about locally
private statistical inference yes so
I'll be talking about locally private
statistical inference communication
samples and shared randomness let's
start by thanking the organizers and
communica literally Alexandra and Adam
for inviting me and for all of you to
for waking up this early in the morning
half of you may be I told you ten times
to come here so you're here regardless
thank you so the stock will be based on
a couple of joint words one of them is
with my students the Tonga and who are
new at Cornell and another work will be
with Cody with a student at Cornell and
Clemmie and Himanshu basically 3:00 a.m.
I think I just woke up and I imagine
that Clemmie is right there with a
weapon because I forgot to put his
accent until yesterday so I put it today
you don't understand what I'm saying you
should go on his Twitter feed and you
can see his posts about accent see you
know the base of plan off the top we'll
talk about privacy again and then we'll
look at two problems distribution
learning and testing the very basic
problems and then we'll end with lower
bonds okay this doesn't give much
information so hopefully and I put here
the basic problems that we will look at
for reference and this picture will come
up in a few moments okay
so we'll consider one particular case of
statistical inference you have will
consider the discrete setting you can
extend most of these to continuous the
distributions as well so you have an
unknown distribution P over a domain of
size K let us say 1 through K and the
distribution is basically a map from 1
through K 2 0 1 that adds up to 1 over
the entire domain and the setting is you
are given iid samples from this
distribution P that you do not know and
you want to solve some inference tasks
on P ok that's the high level goal and
to do it you will need samples you need
to get n samples I guess and the sample
complexity for an inference task will be
defined as the smallest number of data
points that you need to see
the least number of draws to solve that
problem and we look at two fundamental
problems the first is distribution
learning where for any peak once you see
n samples with probability 0.9 over the
draws you want to output a P hat that's
close
that's at least alpha close to the true
distribution in L 1 distance yeah so
this is L 1 learning and again people
have looked at it maybe for centuries
and we know that the example complexity
for this problem grows linearly with the
domain size K and inversely proportional
to the accuracy that you are trying to
achieve and in fact the estimator is
very simple here you just output the
empirical distribution so the
probability you assign to a symbol X is
just how many times X appears in your n
samples divided by n and lower bound is
a classical application of panels
inequality here so that's problem one
which is written here problem two is a
slightly general form over here so you
are given a reference distribution which
in this case we'll just consider the
uniform distribution and so you know
there is so your person if the following
you are given n samples and upon
observing these n samples you have to
decide whether the underlying
distribution is the uniform distribution
or is it at least alpha away from being
uniform so what do you mean by that if
the distribution is uniform with
probability at least 0.9 you have to say
yes it's uniform if it's any
distribution that's Al far away from
uniform again with probability 0.9 you
have to say yes oh no it's away from
uniform and you can replace this you
with any other reference distribution if
you want and the sample complexity it's
a trouble only it will not change let's
say
the sample complexity for this problem
has been established to be square root K
over alpha square so you can do better
than learning and there are many methods
to do it and somehow surprisingly most
of these are in this century however I
think if you go back to Walt's original
paper in 1942 and if you look at his
analysis he actually that's something
very similar to the things that these
younger people are doing and what I mean
by that he basically looked at the
statistic and in the asymptotic analyzed
like they did a normal approximation to
the chi-square statistic and they
obtained something but if you take it
and apply to the setting we have you
will actually get back some of the
letters that we care about and the lower
bound is based on ala camps two-point
method that we are going to see in a
little bit when we talk about lower
bounds so this is the classical
centralized framework where you have
access to all the N samples and what we
will be interested is a framework which
will be basically this picture where
there are n players now this x1 through
xn are distributed over these n players
so player number I hold sample X I which
is drawn independently from P and again
there is a central referee that wants to
solve this problem so what's the setup
without any constraints what will happen
is each player can just send their
samples and you are reduced to the
centralized case no worries but there
may be many constraints for example the
players may not want to share their
excise that's the privacy constraint
they may not be able to send the whole
sample maybe it's a high dimensional
vector and do you have strict
communication constraints maybe over a
tiny mobile device and I think someone
yesterday I was talking to from Google
and they say the communication may be a
bottleneck especially in developing
countries where bandwidth is a big maybe
both so how do they model these
constraints we are going to model these
constraints as a set of channels W which
will be a set of allowed channels so
strip calligraphic W is a set of allowed
channels each element here is basically
a randomized function from k to some
domain so you have this channel input
the set of all samples you can see and
output is something and what player I
does is it's going to select channel WI
from this allowed set of channels and
they receive the sample P after that
they pass their sample through this
channel so nyi and the referee observes
these y1 through yn so that's basically
this picture that will come in the next
slide and then there is a protocol that
decided ahead of time that how these
channels are being chosen by the users
and upon observing this y1 through yn
now that every wants to solve the same
statistical problem that it wanted to do
before any questions about this work
okay so yes like the cept where the
player selects a channel like is that
like a really important step of yes you
could we are going to work in the most
general I'll describe it in the too much
like sorry share the same randomize
function is randomized so each player
can use so okay we are going to make it
very precise in two slides if it doesn't
make sense he lost okay
so pictorially it's this so the players
generate so this distribution generates
these samples distributed across players
each player i passes this through a wi
outcomes why is that this guy observes
and wants to solve the problem okay
let's look at two constraints and then
we look at the setting okay so i
mentioned that you have this
calligraphic w which is you know some
kind of constraint so the first
constraint we will look at is local
differential privacy okay and there are
all the papers that do this i guess the
first one would be warner then the
cleaners paper oh yeah yeah okay so di -
I looked at DSN okay and this is the
setup so every W in this local
differential private is a locally
differentially private channel if this
is oh we're done this I guess all of you
know but stated here so the output could
be any binary string and for any output
you are basically not able to say
whether X generated it or X prime for
any X and X prime that's the definition
for LD P and W epsilon is the set of all
LD p channels the input size K output of
arbitrary size and most of this talk we
are going to look at epsilon to be small
constant sort of one so high privacy
regime I'll just touch upon a little bit
on larger values of Epsilon these are
also mortal communication constraints in
this setting so the script W sub L will
be basically the set of all channels
whose input is of size K there are K
inputs 1 through K output is
Elbert Strix so input of size K and
output of size 2 to the L the disk and
model communication constraints now you
go to the protocols what kind of
protocols we are looking at we'll look
at simultaneous message passing in this
talk what does that mean instead of
saying that messages are being sent
simultaneously I will instead say that
the channels are being selected by the
users at the same time ok even here
there are two kinds of protocols that
we'll look at the first is private coin
protocols so this is the scheme for
private grant protocols each user user I
has its own private randomness UI so
there are end users user I has
randomness UI which is independent of
the other random so you are through UN
are independent random variables UI is
with user I it looks at UI and
instantiation of UI users it to select
this channel yeah that's the general
setting for private cons in public Cohen
protocols what happen is there is some
random variable you let's say the
referee is sending it to all the players
the players can look at this Adam
variable you and select its channel
based on so in the first case the
channels are essentially independent of
each other in the second case the
channels are only independent
conditioned or not independent
okay one of the questions we want to see
is the public coins help if so when if
so why not if not why not
and this can be thought of as a half
round of interaction this is something I
picked up from Aaron while talking
yesterday because because this is not
exactly interaction because you are not
i'm not picking my channel looking at
the outputs of other people but still am
there is some synchronization due to the
public randomness that shared any
questions about this
okay so the first problem we look at is
distribution estimation that I just
discussed here there's a lot of work on
distribution estimation in the past
decade under local differential privacy
to them all of these like the report
paper do change
Jordan win right then Peter had a paper
with one of its an Hommage mini and
Sasha both have a new paper which
actually uses the same scheme as this
nice paper which somehow you know one
wani q young leach out they have their
very nice scheme which is actually what
these guys use for distribution
estimation and then some recent papers
that we have under paper that came out
last week I will talk a little bit I
think for the option distribution
estimation people have looked at how to
do it and how to estimate Gaussian
distributions under privacy including
paper by Gobbo are the Rogers separate
and by just a puka Nemo and Wu and there
is a lot of work on estimating
distributions under global differential
privacy including a bunch of work by
Gotham here
so what do we know okay so the setting
is this each WI is an epsilon locally
differentially private channel your goal
is still to do this you want to output a
distribution whose less alpha away from
the true distribution so now it's well
established that there is a private coin
protocol and we look at one of these
protocols soon we look at two of these
protocols actually there is a private
coin protocol for doing distribution
estimation that requires K over alpha
square which is the centralized
complexity times K over epsilon square
samples so there is this blow-up of
sample complexity which I guess is one
way to see why you say that utility
drops a lot for local differential
privacy so you need a lot more samples
to do the same task and this is the blow
up factor in red so there is a linear
factor blow up in k and this is optimal
in fact it's optimal even when you allow
for public coins or even interactive
protocols and I think John gucci and
ryan rogers they have a recent paper
which shows similar results even with
multiple rounds of interaction the
complexity doesn't change you don't get
any improvement then there are results i
can extend these to all values of
epsilon including the paper by n bug and
rock paper with the tongue and who on
you okay so now we will look at one
simple scheme or not simple actually
we look at rapport basically so i said
that there are all of these the schemes
to do there are all these papers that
deal with discrete distribution
estimation so how do they do it so
basically all of these papers for a
small epsilon regime can be thought of
as just a rapport or rapport plus
epsilon square noise some variant of
rawa
so we're just going to stay proper here
so your input is a k bit is a is an
element from 1 through K that's what
each player observes and the output will
be a K bit binary vector how is this
vector generated you first map X is an
element from 1 through K to a K bit
binary vector where the location X is 1
everywhere else it's a zero so one hot
encoding or
and then you flip each bit independently
by passing it through let's say a binary
symmetric channel with some crossover
probability so it'd be each bit is
flipped with property there and you have
epsilon over 2 because if you have two
different inputs X and X prime the
output distribution over these K bit
vectors will differ only on the X and X
prime location that's 1 over 2 so what's
nice about this scheme it's an optimal
it's a scheme with optimal sample
complexity awesome it's a private coin
protocol and yesterday I was talking to
someone who is not in the audience right
now can't use their name but I can say
that they said at least in some
applications they care about public
coins because maybe you are designing
the hardware or something and it's much
easier to have those protocol that's
already set in let's say you have
already implemented or poor or something
and it's symmetric so each player does
the same thing there so these are three
nice things the con is high
communication cost which will also imply
high computation cost because right now
you are singing at a bit vector instead
of to describe a log domain of size K
you are using K bits so and we don't
know of any other private converter
calls for this problem that have a
better sample complexity of a stencil or
work but there is this beautiful remark
in Basilian Smith in 2015 which the
partly attributed to McGregor we don't
know because the Rheingold Alwar and WOD
on well they say that if you have any
private current protocol for LDP where
you have messages of some size you can
convert it into a public point protocol
where each player sends just one bit
it's that's a beautiful result and the
proof is also very nice if you okay
which is why we are we are now going to
ask ok so if you have public randomness
enough of it maybe every protocol can be
made into one bit but can be do the same
thing with just lower communication with
simpler schemes let's say so to do that
we are going to look at randomized
response and we will use it once we
understand this I think that will take
one minute to explain
we do not propose this randomized
response and an extension was studied by
Peter and Keith and Dan in the rice amel
paper the scheme is the following the
input is of size domain size K output is
also of domain size K so there is no
blow-up and the scheme is the following
you just output the truth if your input
is X your put X with a slightly higher
probability with a probability to the
epsilon times the probability of
outputting any other symbol so you for
input of X you say X with probability to
be epsilon over this and you say
anything else with probability 1 over
this and they will add up to 1 this plus
K minus 1 times this ok what is good
about this game it's a low communication
scheme private coin products and
symmetric but it has a suboptimal sample
complexity and you can you can look at
the paper where they show that there is
so this was optimal the first two terms
were optimal for LDP estimation and now
you have an additional blow-up of k if
you use this skin ok try to see if I try
to motive show why this happens and that
will be used to come up with our
protocol ok before that I'll just state
one result have not stated any result
until now so there is a private coin LD
P scheme so there is no public
randomness that is sample optimal for
distribution learning each your user
does the same scheme they use the same
channels and each player cents at most
log k plus 2 bits so this plus 2 bits is
to maintain some kind of computational
efficiency by using some specific
matrices but you can make it log tape
you want with the same sample complexity
and the running time at each player is
about logarithmic in K I guess if you
count bitwise or poly logarithmic kind
at the server it's linear in both the
number of samples and the domain size
any questions about what this result
says so it's the same thing sample
optimal each player does the same thing
without put is only log cabins yes then
again
communication complexity of the previous
optimal protocol okay
private can win okay I don't know of any
other that does better like if you do
rapport if you look at let's say Gucci
John Jordan Wainwright they also do this
one hot encoding a bar they do something
whose entropy for small epsilon and
uniform distribution is still case so
you can't even hope to compress it look
at the distribution of this K bit of the
output it's pretty high for all those
private coin schemes you can use like
for example what you save is public can
make it one bit but yeah in the private
kong setting this is the best we know
okay so now let's take two more minutes
so let's see what randomized response is
I'm going to describe a randomized
response of the matrix and I just picked
the random number which somehow turns
out to be one less than a power of two
so it's seven I can write randomized
response as a identity matrix where each
input is will be will index a row and
the output will be a column so I see
some input I'm going to send an output
how do I do that so
so your input is X you select the exit
row and you look at that row that has
some bunch of zeros and a single one you
select the location one with a
probability that's e to the epsilon
times the other one this is exactly
randomized response that we described
two slides ago so for example when X is
two you go to the second row you select
location number two which is like a
higher probability otherwise you send
any other location okay now let's see
why is this scheme not the best one
could do that's where we start and
that's where we are going to come up
with our new protocol suppose I want to
solve this hypothesis testing problem I
tell you that the input I'm going to
take one input which is going to be
either of symbol number one or symbol
number two chosen uniformly at random
I'm going to pass this through a private
channel let's say Kay randomized
response you look at the output and your
goal would be to tell me whether the
input was one or two it's a simple
hypothesis testing problem so what will
happen is if your input is one you
select the first row if it's the second
input you select the second row but if
you if your output is anything except
one and two you are getting no
information the distributions over those
outputs is the same under both these
distributions and this is the simple
exercise you can show that the
probability of correct guess is 0.5 plus
order epsilon over K so this epsilon
over K is the thing that's killing
randomize response and what does it
happen it's because any two rows you
take most of the locations they are
matching they differ only on two
locations and that's where you are
sending information so what should you
do you do the most basic thing you can
think of try to come up with rows that
are as far from each other as possible
and that's why that's what we call as
how to mod response so consider of this
matrix which is what and you can guess I
guess this is some 1 by 7 matrix where I
delete the first row and column of the
eight by eight.hoorah mod matrix now
what will happen I do the same thing the
scheme is the same for any given X I
select exit row I select now I'm going
to send a column index I'm going to
select an index with a 1 with a
probability to the epsilon times larger
than an index
zero that's the that's the scheme any
questions about this
so a couple of remarks I can take
actually take any input size care you
can you can even choose this matrix
randomly that will also have optimal
sample complexity we use Hadamard for
computational efficiency because when
you take this matrices it will be
basically computing the inverse horror
mark the getting the density the
distribution back at the server will be
doing a inverse how about transform
which you can do faster if you have this
matrix that's why we use Harmon matrix
any questions about this that's the
whole scheme great question actually I
had a very long I have one slide on that
and I will also mention about Hamid
response briefly and I had a very long
discussion with dr two days ago and if
he was here I would have just pointed
you to him I'll talk about it the use
our mother's matrix for very different
purposes I guess and talk about if I
have time
okay so algorithm is the following you
you can extend it to general K you have
some input of some size you can choose a
high-demand matrix of size order k it
will be slightly larger than K so any
two rows will differ in at least half
the columns and then you can show that
the probability of guessing of guessing
whether the input was one or two for the
same problem that I asked before now
becomes like 1/2 plus epsilon instead of
epsilon over K and this is also optimal
distribution learning and you can do you
can decode it in linear near linear time
by using Fourier transform
any questions
okay sorry question so you said like
pretty much most matrices would have
like two rows differing and half the
column the visa choose and randomly
effect you just pick this the Hadamard
construction to be fast yes
so one of the questions is do we really
need lock K bits for private coin
estimation so let me ask very simple
question I want to do distribution
learning no public coins can I do better
than lock Cabot's any guesses
the question is do we really need
log-cabin yes if we insist on symmetric
skins so if everyone does the same thing
you do need lock Cabot's
okay but if people are allowed to use
different schemes like it's still
private fine you don't tell use any
public cons the schemes are fixed a
priori but there exists a private coin
LDP scheme that sample optimal is not
symmetric anymore because we are two
line proof to show that you do have to
lose symmetry for this and by each user
sends just one bit just send the
basically it'll be flipped in some sense
because you have to agree on the columns
ahead of time that's it that's the whole
thing
instead of wrote co-sign columns and
that will be off there's a tiny
observation that's why I put it in one
slide so heavier I won't have much time
I have like we had a long discussion
with what when we submitted this paper
there was also a review that talked
about the relation to be an ST and then
I had some exchange with Rui about this
so there the problem is this so instead
of a distribution you just have x1
through xn worst case you have to
estimate the frequent items and there's
a long line of work there starting with
I guess the bacilli Smith then B and s T
and one Nelson and stem R then you want
to see another use of one matrix you
should look here I won't go into it
and there for example you can show that
you do need a lot more communication if
you insist on private current protocols
like just because the randomness is not
there anymore you are the worst case
setting you cannot do one bit protocols
for heavy hitters without public
randomness for example the naturally
concludes the part about learning are
there any questions about distribution
learning
all right so we move into testing which
return here our goal is to decide if the
unknown distribution is uniform or alpha
become uniform with optimal sample
complexity in the private setting there
is a lot of work I think the closest is
a horse worth here in 17 so analyzed the
sample complexity of randomized response
which I think they also showed that this
is optimal and then using public coins
by the scheme proposed by BN SD can make
it the order K squared is the complexity
and for global differential privacy
there's a lot of work on hypothesis
testing and long list local differential
privacy and kabardian Rogers had a paper
on Gaussian distributions and then there
is a very recent paper that came out I
think three days ago where Garin and is
the students and collaborator they show
that interactivity does not help for
hypothesis testing for a particular
class of hypothesis so interactivity did
not help for learning is not going to
help for Aaron's work and we are going
to come up with a slightly different
actually for our simple problem we are
going to show that it will public
randomness will have which is like tiny
bit of interaction
there's a dumbing by that let's go at
our results so for distribution testing
if we have private coin protocols what
you can do is if you use rapport or
hardiman response that we've talked
there is a tester who's sample
complexity is square root K over alpha
square times K over epsilon square so
there is a blow-up of K over epsilon
square compare to the centralized case
and any private LDP scheme requires
these many samples so in that sense
rapport is optimal you can't do better
with any other scheme as long as you use
only private coin protocols if you have
public coins there is a public one
protocol which is extremely simple we'll
talk about it the sample complexity
blows up by a factor of only square root
K over epsilon square instead of K over
epsilon square so the blow-up is much
smaller and any public coin scheme will
need this many samples so you can't do
better than this if you have only coin
and we can put it Oh what happened to
the color here anyway these are the
result that affected before and for
distribution testing the optimal sample
complexity becomes from square root k to
k with public coins to K to the 3 over 2
without public coins okay the square
root K centralized K with public coins K
to the 3 over 2 without public coins so
what is the scheme for this public coins
we'll just mention the scheme briefly
then we'll talk a little bit about lower
bounds in the remaining time we have the
scheme is very simple you want to
testify distribution is uniform or not
the referee will just generate a random
subset of size half the domain which I
this I think has been used in many
different forms in many different places
and Clara is going to just take the
indicator of whether their sample
belongs to this subset of the domain and
apply randomized response to it and send
it so player I see the FXI belongs to
the domain if yes sends one with
probability lock it to the epsilon over
2 epsilon plus 1 and this otherwise
that's the whole scheme why we like work
to work with all of the following if the
distribution is uniform and the domain
is half the size of the dome of K then
the probability of the domain is 1/2
uniform distribution and a few more
seconds of what you can show that the
output distribution of Y eyes will also
be Bernoulli 1/2 so that's case one what
is case two if that is if you take a
distribution that's alpha away from the
uniform distribution any total variation
here is a lemma we can prove and you
pick a random subset s of size half of
the domain then with a constant
probability it will be anti concentrated
around half probability at least some
constant it will be at least alpha over
4 K away from alpha over 4 root K away
from being
the distribution is if the distribution
has probability half on all all subsets
of size K over 2 it has to be uniform
the proof is policing man with a long
analysis and I think you can you can
shorten it so now your indicator
variable that each player computes has
bias at least alpha over root K away
from for nearly half now they do the
randomized response on top of this so
that will imply that with probability at
least Omega of 1 the output distribution
will be a wave will have a probability
of 1 being at least alpha epsilon over 4
root K away from
okay let me just finish this book with
this
so the question boils down to this in
the uniform case you have but only
halves in the non uniform case you have
something whose bias is at least as much
away from 1/2 so how many coins
how many tosses do you need to decide
whether a coin is fair or has bias at
least Delta you need 1 over Delta square
samples for us Delta is epsilon alpha
over root K so this many samples suffice
and that's that's it for public coins
any questions about
okay none will look at lower bounds so
here is a general approach that's used
everywhere for testing between two
listed for a composite hypothesis
testing which in our case where you want
to know if your distribution is uniform
or far from uniform well we look at
priors piece of alpha so piece of alpha
denotes a prior over distributions that
are all at least alpha away from uniform
so you have uniform distribution then
you have all the things that are alpha
away p alpha will denote a prior over
these distributions that are alpha away
from uniform and your goal would be to
test between these two am either going
to select this p to be uniform
distribution or i'm going to select it
according to this prior piece of alpha
so once I select this P from this prior
I am going to generate n samples
according to that prior and the course
through the channel you see these things
and you want to solve this looking at y1
through yn you want to say whether it's
case one or case two Allah comes to
parameter basically is that lower bound
here the number of samples you need for
this will translate into a lower bound
for testing so you come up with this
mixture distribution and then you show a
lower bound is any questions about that
brooch question I guess I just I'm
confused by the nomenclature what why is
this what camps
Soula comes to point method essentially
as if you have a composite hypothesis
testing between two classes of
distributions you come up with two
priors over these two things and we look
at the worst case prior to distinguish
between the mixtures this is one special
case there one distribution is fixed you
come up with a prior over the net okay
whatever that's maybe someone who uses
like a much more ah this is it it's is
easy and the perhaps you can just derive
it or maybe you would do it that way but
maybe it was not that common in let's
say sixty year ago so doing it for the
testing problems here we basically came
up with this thing in in order to
characterize this channels which we call
as chi-square fluctuations which is
basically this quantity which says so we
define this Chi square of P alpha which
is the prior over these distributions
and the set of channels W 1 through WN
as the Chi square distance between y1
through yn that have generated under P
alpha and versus uniform so when you
when your distribution is uniform there
will be a distribution over y1 through
yn after the pass through the channels
when there when you choose P according
to this prior P alpha they will induce
some other distribution that will give
you this y1 through and we define that
as the Chi square fluctuation and you'll
see why we need this and how it's used
to prove lower bounds for private and
public coins so what we can say is if
the Chi square distance between the
between the Y's under uniform and P
alpha is small because Chi square is
upper bounded bar is lower bounded by TV
distance you cannot distinguish between
P alpha and uniform
so now how do we use this framework and
the reason to use it is we got very nice
expressions for many of these problems
like privacy or communication
constraints in this setting we can prove
nice bouncing of these fluctuations so
the public coin lower bonds we want to
do this we want to design a prior that's
how you prove lower bounds for public
coin schemes right so you come up with a
prior which is fixed everyone knows and
now you choose your schemes W 1 through
W n that tries to maximize the tie
square distance basically that tries to
beat this prior I try to show that you
can distinguish under this product so
you fix a set of distributions P alpha
such that no matter how you choose the
channels using public randomness or
whatever once you choose them you cannot
solve the problem if this is wrong so
this is a min max problem public coins
is a public on lower bounds is a min max
problem and you can use constructions
that basically for example penance key
used a construction of distributions
where each you make small perturbations
around uniform which is actually
something that ingster has used back way
back in 86
so that's public coin lower bounds and
you can use the same scheme and looking
at the channel the channel will tell you
and the reason we call it chi-square
fluctuation our chi-square contractions
of such contractions is because these
distributions will become closer once
they pass through the channel by data
processing and that's what we want to
capture as a function of the channels
how does the sample complexity change
how do the distributions get closer
that's what we do in this entire thing
and how do you prove lower bounds for
private coins it's the maximum thing
thus first you decide on a choice of
channels that we know it's a W 1 through
W on uou I know the distributions that
you are using to select the channels
once you have the channels now I'm going
to design a prior to pull that channel
so this is the maximum population the
max over channels that you can choose
the best possible channel and then we
select the prior over distribution that
are all alpha far so that the Chi square
distance is still small and once you
have that you cannot that's the basic
philosophy so maximum for public
randomness and min max for randomness
and somehow it turns out that proving
private randomness for us to cuss the
longest time it was that was most
interesting with a public coin somehow
once we had the entire framework set up
the it was not that hard because we knew
what the price should be just take
monies construction or something but
private coin said for every scheme you
have to show that you can do something
to fool it so I just mentioned and I
have five minutes okay we ran out of
we'll have plenty of time left so it's a
brief rough idea of how we construct
these lower bounds so what does every
channel do every channel is giving you a
noisy information about what the sample
is okay so every time you see a wire you
are getting some noisy information about
X I so what we do is we are going so now
suppose you have a set of channels W 1
through W n using this we are going to
construct some positive semi-definite
matrix in k dimensions where the top
eigenvectors of this matrix will tell
you which directions are these channels
giving you the most information about
okay so you have n channels after you
these channels are giving you they will
use information and how do they lose
information that's what we want to
characterize we just one example here so
for example if the largest eigen vector
turns out to be 1 0 0 0 and the
corresponding eigenvalue is large and
everything else is small then somehow
you are only getting information about
probability of symbol 1 and nothing else
so once you fix these w's the channels
they're essentially every time you are
getting information about whether X I
belongs to sunset and which sex are you
getting information about that will be
encoded by this positive semi-definite
matrix that we come up with
and how do you construct priors
basically look at the top icon vectors
of that matrix avoid those directions
because you have infer you get a lot of
information about them so so make sure
that over those directions the
distribution looks very close to uniform
let's say over those elements over the
remaining elements that the channel is
not giving you information about make
sure it's far from you anymore
that's the whole idea and it will turn
out that basically this matrix the
Frobenius norm of this matrix will give
you some kind will give you the public
randomness bounce and the trace norm
will give you the private random
response that's the kind of set of will
we are able to obtain okay that's all I
have about lower bounds without going
into more dirty details I mean defining
this matrix takes a little bit of time
but it's so very simple matrix once you
have once you have the channels the
matrix can be defined without too much
hassle it characterizes basically how
much information you are giving about
each okay somebody we talked about
private coin low communication
distribution learning schemes including
scheme that uses one bit communication
on no public randomness we looked at
optimal bounds for testing private coin
and public coin schemes which are very
different framework to establish lower
bounds for both of these skills and I
think for the communication limited
testing problem with yong-joon right
here we we thought can we take it one
step further like can you characterize
the sample complexity as a function of
the amount of sheer randomness that you
have amount of public randomness can do
with one bit what can I do with Lakia
bits and is direct trade off there like
with the will the sample complexity
change nicely with the amount of public
randomness available and we show that
there is the expressions looked much
more ugly but it it's still very
interesting actually okay I'll stop
there
[Applause]
we have tried to take one or two
questions
can you give an intuition as to why
testing is hard we want by privacy that
marking the testing is harmed more by
privacy than hurt it's in what sense so
the I might have misunderstood the thing
is under privacy constraints if you have
for learning you can come up with simple
schemes that can't be improved whether
you have interactivity or whether you
have adaptive protocols or you have
public randomness for distribution
testing of this composite hypothesis
where you want the goodness of fit
problem where you want to set P versus
not P in a distributed setting the
sample complexity or the rates for
public Rand for schemes that don't have
public randomness can be much more than
schemes that do have public randomness
it's almost like you have an Origin that
you have to distinguish from all the
things that are far from origin or what
we are saying is if you don't have
public randomness somehow you have to
find this tiny circle that's a way that
you use to differentiate the origin from
everything else when you have public
randomness what you do is you somehow
take a random hyperplane and after the
distributions are fixed you take a
random hyperplane and you can show that
somehow that will be enough to give you